hey guys it is the 29th up November my
name is Jess and here's the things that
mattered in gaming today first up of the
year 2 season pass for Rainbow six siege
is now available on the PlayStation and
Xbox store the thirty dollar season pass
includes eight new year to operators
over four seasons eight exclusive
headgear and uniform customizations a
rainbow six carbon charm for your gun
and 600 rainbow six credits to purchase
in-game content there are also VIP perks
including seven day early access to each
seasons new operators a 10-percent
discount in the in-game shop a
five-percent renowned boost to unlock
in-game content faster and two extra
daily challenges these VIP membership
bonuses will be available until februari
7 of 20 18 Ubisoft haven't yet said when
season 2 content will be rolling out a
report has indicated that the xbox one
sold more than the PlayStation 4 during
Black Friday's online sales in the US
Adobe claims at the top 5 best selling
electronic products for Black Friday
were iPads samsung 4k TVs macbook air LG
TVs and xbox consoles Adobe didn't
mention where the ps4 ranked but it
doesn't appear to have cracked the top 5
products the xbox one s and ps4 slim
were both offered for 250 bucks on Black
Friday and each was bundled with at
least one game adobe reported that
overall black friday online sales
amounted to 5.2 7 billion which is up
17.7 percent from last year from the
period of November 12 24 the ps4
remained the best-selling console with
Xbox one coming in second according to
the report the Xbox one has been the
best-selling console in the US since
July in terms of game sales Pokemon Sun
and Moon came out on top according to
Adobe followed by call of duty which is
presumably a reference to infinite
warfare finally my favorite Elder
Scrolls game oblivion is now available
on Xbox one backwards compatibility the
steady stream of new backwards
compatible games are still flowing and
today Microsoft have added oblivion
trying to medal of honor airborne and a
step up to the roster
all of those games are playable right
now if you own any of them digitally
they should show up automatically in
your ready to download list on the
system alternatively you can grab them
from the xbox store or pop in your
physical disk to get stuck in do let me
know Danny in that comment box what you
cared about today ahead to game spot for
our last guardian unboxing and I will
see you again tomorrow